Prince Harry and Megan's Netflix
docu-series dropped just a short time
ago it is called Harry and Megan watch
this all right
[Music]
why did you want to make this
documentary
[Music]
no one sees what's happening behind the
closed doors
foreign
[Music]
everything I could to protect my family
[Music]
when the stakes were this high
doesn't make more sense to hear our
story from us
[Music]
I see your visit to Boston and raise you
one docu-series I see that is a very
good trailer I can't wait to see it what
do we think is going on there what do we
think I mean there's always what do you
mean there's a lot of subtext in the
images that you're showing I don't see
any subtext at all please tell me what
is happening well I mean you see her in
moments of distress right looking at her
phone for whatever reason you see her
you see the prince and princess of Wales
in a very sort of not flattering warm
photo was not look at these photos
engineering Megan they're looking at
whatever is going on but what I think
what selection of the photo they chose
for the trailers you're right that is
very editing that that's a very
conscious choice but I thought Megan
some did it well when she said shouldn't
shouldn't we be the ones that get to
tell ourselves the mistakes are so hot
yes because everybody else has been
telling me everybody's been telling it
and now you get to hear from them what
their story is I think it's great oh I
see that yeah I see that shot you're
talking about okay my eyes are open in a
new way here yeah it was very intense it
it looks very interesting and deliberate
and deliberate and it do we think it's a
coincidence that they dropped it today
when or is it when does it start when
does it start well so did they drop it
when does it that is a good question
when does this thing drop but do we
think it's a coincidence that they drop
at the same that they dropped the trails
did they I call that genius
now is the moment hire that marketing
executive hit the button yeah let me
tell you about something
that's right they really figured it out